en 2018 la nominación del conservador
webcam en off como juez de la corte
suprema sacudió a eeuu la máxima
instancia judicial del país que tiene la
última palabra sobre los grandes temas
de la sociedad tales como el derecho al
aborto el porte de armas la inmigración
de los derechos de la población lgbt y
se inclinaba hacia una mayoría
conservadora de 5 a 4 antes de que el
senado les dé su aprobación los jueces
de la corte suprema son nominados por el
presidente de eeuu en su puesto
vitalicio una designación que puede
impactar en la política de la unión
americana de manera perdurable no es por
tanto una sorpresa que las nominaciones
a la corte suprema constituyan un gran
desafío político
a designación de un nuevo juez por parte
de donald trump a green daría una
considerable ventaja a los conservadores
6 contra 3 es por eso que el trump cuyo
mandato presidencial está en juego
quiere actuar rápido antes de las
elecciones del 3 de noviembre algo a lo
que se oponen con fuerza los demócratas
yo byd en su adversario electoral le
pide el senado que no vote antes de los
comicios en 2016 año electoral el senado
se había negado a votar sobre un
candidato nombrado por el ex presidente
barack obama argumentando que no podría
tomar tal decisión en medio de una
contienda electoral cuatro años más
tarde el líder de los republicanos en el
senado parece no recordar ese episodio
mitch mcconnell y ha dejado saber que
organizaría una votación sin drama trump
anuncia su elección